High Crime Vatican City... and 7 other Amazing
Facts
1.
Wikipedia to date has taken about 100 million
man-hours to create.
This may sound like a lot, but in fact in
a typical month, people in the U.S. alone
spend about 1.5 billion man hours watching
advertisements on TV.
(QF 473)
2.
Alaska is the Eastern, Western, and Northern
most state in the U.S..
How?
Some of the Aleutian islands that are part
of Alaska cross the 180 meridian line, which
is the marker between “East” and “West”
(QF 441)
3.
The highest crime rate per capita of any city
in the world is at Vatican City where an average
of 600 crimes are committed per year, despite
only having 800 residents.
(QF 459)
4.
The Sun is 20 “years” old in Sun years.
You see, it’s completed about 20 orbits
around our galaxy’s center since it first
sparked to life.
(QF 467)
5.
The Jews were not the only civilization to
mark a great flood that seemingly covered
the Earth for a certain period (note: 40 days
and 40 nights was just a Jewish expression
that meant "a really long time" and didn't
necessarily literally mean 40 days and 40
nights).
Here is a small subset of other cultures that
had similar stories:
a.
Ancient Greek literature states that "Zeus
sent a flood to destroy the men of the Bronze
Age.
Prometheus advised his son Deucalion to build
a chest after floating in the chest for nine
days and nights, landed on Parnassus.
When the rains ceased, he sacrificed to Zeus,
the God of Escape."
b.
Lithuanian legend states that water once covered
the Earth for a period of 20 days and 20 nights.
Those few who survived were 9 couples, from
which the Lithuanian tribes originated, according
to their legend.
c.
Burmese legend says that when the great flood
came, a brother and sister took refuge in
a boat.
The sister later gave birth, but a witch cut
the baby into pieces; the pieces of the baby
struck the ground and the nations of the Earth
sprung up from the slain child's body parts.
d.
Transylvanian legend says a certain man announced
the coming of a cataclysmic flood.
According to their legend, the predicted flood
lasted an entire year.
e. Sacramento Indian legend states that a
great flood once covered the Earth that lasted
"9 sleeps".
f.
According to Chinese legend, the Earth was
covered in a great flood and only 2 children
survived in a gourd; the period of the flood
was 99 days.
From the two children came 12 offspring from
which the nations of the Earth arose.
6.
During WWII, all the snakes and dangerous
insects were killed in the London Zoo by the
Zoo keepers in case they managed to escape
after a bombing.
(QF 451)
7.
The 1900 Olympics included a long jump competition…
for horses.
(QF 453)
8.
Oranges are a berry, as are bananas.
Strawberries however are not technically berries,
they are aggregate fruits.
(QF 458)